[Music]
do this week on q a
our guest is ross douthit
at age 29 he's the new op-ed columnist
for the new york times replacing bill
crystal
[Music]
ross doubt that i'm looking at a march
12 2009 story in the new york times and
the headline is times hires new
conservative columnist
the question to you is have you ever
seen them write a headline times hires
new liberal columnists
um
i haven't
but
they
i guess the times most of the times this
liberal calmness have been promoted from
within haven't they so
you know whether whether or not they
would run such a headline they probably
haven't had the chance to in a long time
don't they have any conservatives inside
that they can hire and with well i've
you know i've i've only been at the
times for a couple weeks but i've
already met people
working for the paper of all kinds of
political opinions so i don't think it's
completely true that the times is
monolithically liberal in your book
privilege you wrote about the times
being a daily bible at harvard explain
that
well i think that the times and this has
been true for a long time but i think
it's particularly true now has very
effectively positioned itself as not
just a new york newspaper but a national
newspaper and a national newspaper for
the upper middle class american elite
of which harvard is obviously
essentially a finishing school of sorts
for that slice of the population and so
the times is
part of the culture of a place like
harvard and um
i think in in
a very profound way actually it's sort
of the the gold standard of
of journalism
broadly but also
it reflects again broadly speaking the
world view um of the class that reads it
every morning or now in the internet age
at 9 00 a.m and 10 47 a.m and 2 52 p.m
and so on across the day online how many
columns have you written for them two
and
the youngest
columnist on the op-ed page in history
um i'm told that yes although i'm not on
the op-ed page yet they have me writing
an online column
for the first two months so i haven't
yet appeared in the newspaper itself
they're giving me a sort of break-in
period to
get used to the medium i think so what's
your deal with them how did they who
came to you how did this happen uh they
approached me for some conversations um
what is it now it's it's may so they
they approached me several months ago um
and i had one conversation with um
with some of the editors in new york and
then
some time after that i went up to new
york again and had a conversation i met
arthur salzberger the publisher
and then at some point i'd say four or
five weeks after that they called me up
and offered me the job
and i accepted
so what does it mean i mean is it a
full-time job it's a full-time job yep i
work for the times now
and i'm there
i think there's sort of an
uh
two-year a two-year contract overall but
it's it's somewhat open-ended and i
think that they probably have the right
to fire me two months in if i do
anything disastrous so so how much of a
guarantee do you have that you'll end up
in the paper itself um i i they've
promised me that i will so i take them
at their word
what impact did this have on your
thinking i mean you go back in your book
you wrote on harvard was what year um it
came out i think in 2005. what would all
those buddies of yours that you room
with back in harvard think now well i
don't i mean they they sent me emails so
i i know i know what they think i'm
still friends with most of them and i i
mean i think everybody was
everybody was very
i mean they were very happy for me
obviously it's an it's an incredible
opportunity
um and
you know i mean i i think that they
yeah they were happy for me i guess
what's it mean to you
well it's um
i'd say in a certain respect and i don't
want to overstate this because i'll make
myself nervous but it's obviously i'd
say journalistically the chance of a
lifetime i mean it's an
unparalleled platform
um
in an age when there really aren't that
many unparalleled platforms left i think
we've entered an era of incredibly
incredibly fragmented media where
everybody's getting their news um and
information and so on from niches and
you know the times is itself a niche but
it's as niches go it's a pretty large
one um and it's an opportunity to speak
i think
you know to people around the world and
to have your opinions be taken seriously
and hopefully i'll be up to the
challenge
what does the times expect of you
i mean what point of view are they
expecting from and they haven't they've
i they've made no
requests for a particular point of view
and i in fact i think that um in spite
of what the headline said they're
resistant to the idea that they've hired
me as a
you know a token another conservative
columnist for their to to be alongside
david brooks i'm i think that they and
hopefully they'll be vindicated
look at the hiring as a chance to get a
distinctive voice regardless of what um
his particular politics happened to be
so they haven't said we want you to
write about the republican party and we
i mean i think they obviously know what
my interests are i'm interested in
politics i'm interested in religion i'm
interested in the culture
and i assume they expect me to write
about those topics
give us a couple of paragraphs on what
you think the future of the republican
party
is
well
i think there are a number of possible
futures i think the republican party is
to make a very broad generalization
roughly where the democratic party was
around the time that ronald reagan was
elected president which is to say it's
coming off a long period of of political
dominance
and it's lost its dominance temporarily
and the question is how long will take
um how long will it take for the party
to come back come back politically
come back and come back intellectually
as well in terms of the quality of the
policy ideas that it's putting forward
and i think those two things are
interrelated um you know people in
washington and people who write about
policy like me often tend to overstate
how much policy matters and you don't
want to overstate it it's true that you
know the biggest reason that the
democrats swept into power um over the
last two to four to four years is the
combination of the war in iraq and
hurricane katrina which was neither of
which were a matter of you know the
democrats suddenly coming up with a
bunch of brilliant new policy ideas it
was the failures of the republicans that
catapulted them to power
that being said i think that there is a
certain
there's a baseline that a political
party needs to hit a baseline of um
seeming intellectually serious seemingly
engaged in the work of governance
and it's not a baseline that the
democratic party really seemed to hit
successfully um
in the late 70s and early 1980s and i
don't think it's a baseline the
republican party is hitting today
and i think that you know john mccain's
campaign against barack obama obviously
mccain was in a very difficult position
from the start barack obama was probably
going to win that election no matter
what just because of how the country
thought about george w bush and the
republicans and also because of the
collapse of the global economy but i
think that if you watched mccain's
campaign it was a shockingly
content-free campaign a sort of
accumulation of gimmicks and gambits and
ticks and and jabs without any kind of
an animating vision and i think that
that's something the republican party
needs to recover and it will recover it
eventually the question is just how long
does it take who are your favorite
political thinkers
um contemporary all time any any time i
had to name five people that you
have followed and admired their thinking
not their politics so much but how they
think
just take a shot at it take a shot at it
okay well maybe i'll i'll start with um
a sort of unorthodox choice which is
christopher lash
who's
the author of a book that was very
influential on my thinking and the
writing of privilege the book you
mentioned about harvard um a book called
the revolt of the elites uh which came
out i believe in the early 1990s but a
book essentially about the nature of um
of the american upper class as it was
developing um in in the knowledge
economy basically and a sort of mobile
large scale the first mass upper class
in history
that was
essentially the end point of a very
efficient meritocratic system and lash
mounted i think a pretty compelling
critique of this class which was
it was similar to the neoconservative
critique starting in the 1970s of this
new class that they were essentially
disconnected from the ordinary life of
the american public um
and that they tended to be hostile to
the values and mores and often the
religious and socially conservative
values and more race of the american
public
a second okay um
well if i can if i can lump them
together and if that's okay i i would
say
also the
original generation of neoconservatives
um who um and especially in their
domestic policy thinking i think that we
tend to think of neoconservatism today
as um primarily a foreign policy
oriented
ideology
and and coming out of the 1990s and then
obviously the period around 9 11 in the
war in iraq of a strand of conservatism
very much focused on the projection of
american power abroad but the original
generation of of neoconservatives
figures like
figures like irving crystal figures like
that social scientists like james q
wilson the people who
coalesced around magazines like the
public interest and so on were figures
whose primary interest in many cases was
in domestic policy and was in a critique
of the liberal welfare state
that recognized that the welfare state
probably wasn't going away
um and and i think that that's it's that
kind of critique hopefully that
animates a lot of what i've written
about domestic the impact on you that
you took
bill crystal's place at the new york
times who is the son of irving crystal
matter no i don't i don't think so and i
think people make way way too much of
this kind of i mean i think as i said
before the idea that there's just a
conservative slot um that needs to be
filled i don't think that that's
that's really true at all and i'm very
friendly with bill crystal he took me
out to lunch after i took the job at the
times and gave me advice and and was
very
um very generous and kind about the
whole thing
third
on this list
um third on this list uh i'll i'll make
an obvious choice and say william f
buckley jr um just in terms of his i i
think that
he particularly you know you really
obviously can't say enough about
buckley's capacity for
building and you know starting with
national review and building a sort of
intellectually serious conservative
movement at a time when conservatism was
considered completely unserious but i
think the specific thing about about
buckley that i really admire is his
recognition that you ha you can't just
be
an if you're going to be an intellectual
engaged in politics you have to be an
intellectual who's engaged with american
populism
and the temper of american conservatism
i think has always been very populist
and sometimes in good ways sometimes in
destructive ways
but i think conservative intellectuals
before buckley often tried to completely
hold that populism at arm's length and
you know um
so you had general conservative
intellectuals in the 30s and 40s were
essentially irrelevant to american
politics i mean what buckley made the
leap to saying i'm going to be an
intellectual but i'm going to be an
intellectual who's really good friends
with ronald reagan um and who's engaged
in and ronald reagan was a populist
and but that sort of buckley reagan
friendship i think is the pattern is a
great pattern for
people who are interested in thinking
and writing but also interested in
political engagement his book that he
wrote what was it 1954 man and got it
yeah got a minute yeah
did that have any impact on you and why
you wrote the book on harvard called
privilege
it had some impact obviously you can't
be a conservative writing a book about a
liberal institution without having
gotten mad at yale in some sense as your
touchstone i i think that looking
re-reading got a man at yale before i
wrote about harvard though what was
striking to me was just how completely
different the landscape was that buckley
was writing about versus the landscape
that i was writing about he he was
writing about a period um
you know on the one hand where it was
still a matter for debate for serious
debate whether places like yale should
be christian universities and buckley
critiqued yale for abandoning its
christian faith and i think the
president of yale came out immediately
and said that's ridiculous yale has
always been a christian institution
that's obviously not something you could
imagine happening in the ivy league
today
so in that sense i think the the
universities have swung much further
away from
well conservatism broadly understood but
but also but at the same time buckley's
writing about communism and communism as
a live issue communism as something that
is
that the universities are essentially
favorable to in in his telling and by
the time i arrived at harvard in the
late 1990s
if communism was not a going thing and
the ivy league especially in the late
90s the period of the tech boom and so
on was the high water mark i think of a
sort of left-of-center politics that was
very much focused on free markets very
much focused on capitalism and i think
arguably to a fault
the pendulum had swung so far in the
opposite direction that
harvard harvard had become a place that
was just channeling people into
investment banking and consulting as
that this was
at that point
it felt like the purpose of the
institution is it true that you went
skinny dipping with bill buckley it's
true that i went skinny dipping with
bill buckley yeah what was the occasion
i was an intern at national review
in the summer of 2001
and
buckley
made it a habit i think of being very
kind to the interns and he was no longer
directly involved with the magazine at
this point but i and my fellow intern
were invited to one of the editorial
dinners at his house we were invited out
to lunch with him and then we were
invited on to go sailing with him and he
went sailing
obviously in all weathers and all times
and we spent a night with him and
the his boat boy every summer he hired
uh someone usually from yale to assist
him with the boat and we sailed out on
the long island sound sailed across to
long island had a extremely uh rich meal
that was prepared for us by by his chef
back home and then and then we went
swimming
because and you know when william
buckley says let's go swimming you go
swimming
anything unusual about that for you
um it was an unusual experience all told
i mean i think that
you know buckley and there have been
there's been so much written about him
um since his death obviously by people
who know him far better than i did but
he really really was a throwback at a
self-conscious throwback i think to just
a completely different era of
you know this this kind of sort of
daredevil aristocrat in a way which is i
think something that american life never
had that many of but certainly doesn't
have that that many of today but i think
that you know the skinny dipping was
just sort of a of a piece with the you
know the sort of post-prep school
culture and um
i'd say but
yeah he was he was an extraordinary
figure
you worked at the magazine i worked at
the magazine yes but for for as an
intern for three months
fourth on your list fourth back to the
thinkers yeah we got we got five of them
we've got we've got five of them and it
doesn't have to be contemporary who
would you pick in in history that you
read when you're you know maybe when you
started thinking for a living i started
thinking um
right so there's gk chesterton um and
i'm a convert to catholicism i converted
when i was 17 so i'm not quite an adult
convert um so i'm somewhere between the
zeal of the convert and the sort of
relaxed attitude pentecostalist before
that we were yeah it's sort of a long
and involved story but i was baptized
episcopalian
and raised episcopalian but at the same
time my parents and especially my mother
were very involved with charismatic
christianity and we went to faith
healing services
and through that we became involved in
my parents helped run a small
charismatic church at yale university
actually for a little while in my
childhood and we went to
various pentecostal gatherings um and
then at a certain point um led by my
mother we all converted to catholicism
so we basically did the complete tour of
american christianity from sort of
mainline protestants through the
evangelical and pentecostal world and
ending up in the catholic church but for
me it was a tremendous tremendous relief
because i
never really
you know the the whole the church
services featuring spontaneous prayer
and so on were agony for an adolescent i
think and you know being being asked to
sort of do
to practice religion performatively and
so on and i was
you know i think i have sort of an
instinctive aesthetic conservatism and
um when my mother became interested in
the catholic church i became very
interested in the catholic church
and chesterton who is sort of a classic
author for uh would-be converts and
especially would-be literary converts to
read
was someone i devoured at that point um
probably read you know eight of his
books in the space of a year and a half
or two years at that point books like
orthodoxy and the everlasting man and
yeah he wrote biographies of saint
thomas aquinas and francis of assisi and
so on um and so
he it's it's sort of a cliche to be a
catholic convert who reads chesterton
but there's a reason it's a it's a
cliche um
so he would be the fourth and then i
guess for the fifth i'll pick j.r
tolkien just just because why not um
because
i think that
you know it's it's calling tolkien a
thinker as opposed to an artist is
you know it's a stretch in certain
respects but i think
uh
if there was any author who dominated my
my childhood um and i'm close enough to
my childhood that it's still pretty
important um i think it was probably
tolkien
let's go through the basics uh you were
born in what town i was born in san
francisco
in 1979
in november in november of 1979 so just
yes i just experienced the 70s um the
reason i mentioned november is this
network started in march of 1969 at 17
17 79 so you were so so so c-span was
here before before you were born i don't
know why it matters but i just thought
it was interesting uh
to have you sitting in that chair
sitting in that chair yeah no here here
i am um i hear the world was an
interesting place before even before i
got here though so but no my parents my
father had been in law school um and my
mother was an english graduate student
at berkeley
and so i was born out west my father's
family is from southern california and
my mother's family is from maine and
shortly after i was born my parents
moved briefly to maine and then ended up
going south and we ended up in new haven
connecticut which is where my mother had
uh she'd gone to yale it was in the
first class of women and then i grew up
in new haven and spent the next 18 years
of my life there and their politics
their politics my they were
died in the wool liberals when i was
young um
they
you know
i i wouldn't say hippies precisely but
close enough
to the counterculture both from their
time in in
berkeley but also in in southern
connecticut i went to a fairly
alternative
school when i was little and my first
political memory is uh being four years
old and going down to the polling place
not understanding anything about
politics but remembering my mother
saying i wanted to grab every woman
walking in and tell her to vote for
geraldine ferraro
so so that was that was childhood and
the first election i paid any attention
to is bill clinton in 92 and i was all
for bill clinton
um
but my but
all
both myself and my parents moved
rightward in different ways i think the
influence of religion was was very
important i think we were sort of
classic cases of uh people for whom
abortion in particular became an issue
that
separated us from
the mainstream of liberalism in the
democratic party i think in my case i
took it further than
my mother became more conservative than
my father and i became more conservative
than either of them i started reading
national review and so on in part as i
think a kind of rebellion against
you know the sort of liberal culture of
suburban new haven connecticut um you
went to high school where hampden hall
country day school in hampden just
outside new haven is it has does it have
a religious connection it does not no
and you were there for how long i was
there for six years junior high in high
school in a word or in a sentence what
impact did that experience have on you
in a
word um in a sentence or two
i mean
i think that
there were three private schools around
new haven hampton hall hopkins and
choate and i think of those the
atmosphere at hampden hall was probably
the most like
what you would have had from a good
public high school in the 1950s and 60s
and so it's but it sort of left me
i
i liked hamden hall a lot
but it
i'm not i'm not coming up with a good
one sentence answer
i guess i would say it was sort of an
odd middle ground between
a world that i didn't experience at all
until i got to college which is the
world of real prep schools and private
schools guests in the world of sort of
public high schools what i actually was
looking for is intellectual intellect
when did you begin to start
thinking like you do now before or
after harvard in high school
in high school i was a sort of i was a
rebellious conservative in a school
where most of the teachers were liberals
most of my friends were liberals of one
kind or another um and then
so i went to harvard a conservative and
if you go to harvard as a conservative
one of two things will happen either you
will be immediately shocked out of your
conservatism by the sort of dominant
liberal mentality or you will become
much more secure in your conservatism
and
i became much more secure i edited the
campus conservative newspaper uh coma
harvard said the harvard salient yes and
i wrote um i wrote a column for the
harvard crimson and it was a
conservative column and i was i guess
one of the small group of well-known
conservatives in in my class um
and harvard was just such
you know
it was simultaneously a place that had
as i said it had moved to the center it
was very you know it was a very
commercial
place very focused on material
acquisition but it was also a place
filled with wacky left-wing identity
politics and so on it was very easy to
be a conservative just sort of poking
fun at all of that and throwing darts i
want to come back to harvard but after
harvard where have you been between
harvard and now i've been at the
atlantic um
for my entire career until now atlantic
month the atlantic monthly although it's
no longer it's now just the atlantic um
owned by owned by david bradley who is
he is um he um
he made his fortune in health care
consulting and other forms of consulting
and now owns a small media empire
very small it's the atlantic national
journal the
political publication government
executive it's sort of washington
centered
is there any way i mean there are a lot
of different people people know like
james fallows and
james bennett doesn't need the editor
james bennett is the editor michael
kelly was the editor
excuse me
when i started uh he died who died in
iraq he died in iraq and but i started
as a researcher
the magazine was based in boston when i
started and i started as a researcher in
the washington office um and then
eventually
the magazine moved from boston to
washington so i've been in washington
the whole time but the magazine itself
has not how many other people at that
magazine would think like you
uh exactly like me none i think or
concern conservatively i mean i think
that the
um
i think that the atlantic
certainly is
it's a non-ideological magazine it's a
magazine i think that
from my point of view tilts liberal um
but
makes an incredible effort to be home
to a broad diversity of voices um and i
think that you know if you go down the
roster of people who regularly write for
the the atlantic you're looking at
people like james fallows people like
robert kaplan um writers like caitlyn
flanagan and sandra singh lowe who are
critics of feminism there are it's often
people writing critically about
liberalism from within the liberal tent
as opposed to from from outside it but
the atlantic is also a place that
published um
i mean if you going back to the 1990s it
published dan quayle was right
the famous cover story by barbara defoe
whitehead about out of wedlock births it
published james q wilson's broken
windows piece in the 1980s that helped
spark the revolution in crime fighting
it published just an excerpt from dinesh
d'souza's a liberal education i mean
it's always been a place that has been
home to
both liberals and conservatives and i
think that that's a that's one of its
strengths and one of the things that
magazines should aspire to and you were
there seven years seven years and then
what and then um i was still there when
the times offered me a job so i left the
atlantic to go to the times
and you're married i'm married for how
long and who did you marry um i've been
married for um a year and september
october november seven months
and i married um abigail tucker who was
um
who i met at harvard who's now a writer
for smithsonian magazine
now there's a value it we found this out
after we asked you to come do this today
uh
but you also have done some things on
blogging heads dot tv yes
it turns out in the audience i don't
know this but there's no connection at
all the first dollar to start c-span
came from the same man that gave their
first dollar to blogging heads really tv
bob rosenkrantz i just want
everybody to know that but that also has
and i'm going to run a clip here from
your
your uh
short clip back and forth with chris orr
of the new republic where you have two
different points of view uh but and
we're just going to see a little bit
before we do though what is this what is
bloggingheads.tv
um blogging heads is it's an basically
an online talk show
about politics but also about science uh
culture ideas and so on and it gets
it gets two people usually bloggers but
often not often people who are authors
of various kinds
and it puts each of them in separate
rooms they're often in separate places
gives them a camera hooks them up and
creates a split screen conversation
and it usually lasts about an hour and
it's basically an attempt to do on the
internet in some sense a lot of what
what c-span does so it makes sense that
some of the but but to basically create
room for
more informed and sustained debate than
you get from
say you know nightly cable tv show
because you're just dealing you're
dealing with one people who might in
some cases might not be asked
to come for a two second you know a
two-minute sound bite on fox or msnbc
and also giving them much more room to
play and go back and forth
um with with somebody else so they'll
have you know they'll have
um
you know
francis fukuyama being interviewed by
somebody and i mean it's it it can be it
can be lowbrow but it's often very high
brow but unlike c-span it is for profit
uh it is for profit you'll have robert
wright who is who's the founder who's
also the
well-known author of um non-zero and the
moral animal but um but yes i think he
takes this sort of entrepreneurial side
of it very seriously all right let's
just watch a minute or so and so people
can see what it looks like
i think that the sentence in which judd
apatow with with knocked up and before
that the 40 year old virgin is doing a
kind of
you could call it like socially
conservative raunch i think that there
there is sort of a subversively like pro
virginity message of the 40 year old
virgin and then well but yeah i guess
i'll going on with this i i think that
both both knocked up and juno have an
implicit um
it's not a politically pro-life message
in the sense that like these are not
briefs for overturning roe v wade or
instituting penalties for abortion but
both movies are pretty clearly pro-life
in the broader sense that um whatever
the politics of the screenwriter or
director
the way they handle abortion treats
abortion as a very bad thing to do
uh well here's where we can start
disagreeing good
really just to show what like i said
very high brow you know people talking
pompously about judd apatows movies yeah
you're talking about movies we're
talking about yeah um i want to go to
your book privilege uh
what year was it published 2005.
and
where did you get the idea and it's it
was published by a major house hyperion
disney company how how did you get to
the point where you had a book at
how were you in 2005. i was 25. and when
did you start writing the book i was in
the fall of
probably the fall of 2002 so i would
have been 23. why did you think at that
age you had a book in you
well i was young and arrogant i mean i
think that that's you know that goes
without saying if you're going to try a
project like that at that age
but i got out of harvard and i had just
started working at the atlantic and
i think a large part of it was that i
just missed harvard tremendously and i
spent four years writing about writing
about harvard non-stop
for the conservative paper for the
harvard crimson
and
you know a lot of what i wrote was sort
of
straightforwardly political you know
what's going on with bush versus gore in
2000 and so on but a lot of it
especially after a certain point was
about the culture of the place um the
culture of elite undergraduate education
in the united states which
struck me and obviously i was there it
would strike me that way as just an
absolutely fascinating topic and harvard
as an absolutely fascinating place and
um it see it seemed unlikely that and
it's and it still does that i will ever
be
as as immersed in another place
that's as interesting to write about um
and that's as interesting and as small
and sort of self-contained you can write
a book about harvard i think in a way
that you it's harder to write a book
about obviously washington is
fascinating and new york is fascinating
but they aren't
discreet places like harvard i think in
the same way so i came out with
um with all these sort of scattered
thoughts that i'd been writing and it
and it seemed to me that it had been a
long time
since anyone had tried to write a sort
of student's eye view look at a place
like that
and i think that you know in terms of in
in terms of the book itself undoubtedly
my youth and inexperience was a weakness
but hopefully my proximity to the place
was a strength i think that the i think
that the book is
is is raw in good ways and in bad but
hopefully
honest in in certain ways in a way that
maybe i wouldn't have been if you know
to write if you were writing it 20 years
on
back to 2002 for a moment just
who did you pick who'd you pick up the
phone call how did you pitch somebody i
i had my one of my close friends at the
atlantic um had interviewed for a job
with an agent ray segalin
who's one of the bigger agents in
washington d.c
and i should say the biggest agent rafe
if you're watching this and
she said she he had said to her you know
oh you know you went to harvard if you
ever know any young harvard authors um
let me know and um i and i had just sort
of basically i just been puttering
around with this for about six months
while i was you know at night um and and
on the weekends and so on and i had
about three sort of essay-ish chapters
and i mentioned this to her and she said
oh you should send it to
um to my friend rafe and so i did and
and he said this is interesting i think
you should write write me an outline and
i wrote an outline and he said well
write this chapter um because it'd be
interesting to see how that works out so
i wrote one one more chapter and on the
basis of that we we sold the book and
then i wrote the rest of it how did it
do
um i
it um i don't think it was a roaring
success um it came out
it came out in the wake actually of well
it came out while the the sort of last
wave of the various larry summers
controversies
that were going on why was there a
conversation this was it was when larry
summers was finally pressured into
resigning as the president of harvard um
and the proximate cause um was the
remarks he made about women in science
and female intelligence and the female
under-representation in the sciences
but there were broader forces at work
having to do with his management of the
university the faculty disliked him for
all sorts of reasons and basically
forced him out and this was going on as
the book came out and it created
tremendous interest in harvard but it
created i think the wrong kind of
interest for the purposes of a book like
this because people wanted to talk about
faculty politics and want to talk about
larry summers and issues of um political
correctness and and and so on um and i
was i was
selling a book basically that was about
undergraduate culture which was not what
the summer's controversy was focused on
it also came out after um
tom wolf's i am charlotte simmons had
come out about
six months nine months before and i
think that that cast a long shadow and
so did um curtis sittenfeld's book
prepped which was not about it was a
novel uh about a private school not a
non-fiction memoirish book about a
university but
there was
there were similar things going on and
her book was fantastic and a deserved
success our last two presidents went to
harvard um and lots of others
here in this town have been to harvard
but from your perspective how important
is harvard to the running of this
country
well it depends what you mean i mean
it's not important in the sense there
isn't a conspiracy where
the president of harvard is you know has
tremendous influence over
over the actual specific policies that
are said and so on i mean it's a mistake
to regard the ivy league the way some
people regard say the bilderbergers or
the trilateral commission and so on um
what it what it is harvard is part of
an elite culture that
encompasses a place like washington dc
um and and harvard harvard is part of
the educational system that produces the
people who run the united states of
america and so understanding that
culture is tremendously useful when it
comes to understanding you know why
policy happens the way it happens what
are what are the basically what are the
prejudices of the people who go into
elite institutions how big is it
how big is how many kids go there i mean
uh
1600 to 2000 graduate every year um but
harvard
in the book i i argued and i think
accurately that
looking at harvard is a way to look at
a much broader network of schools of
which harvard is sort of at least if you
believe the u.s news rankings at the top
but there's a there's a we now have a
vast network of colleges and
universities and liberal arts colleges
in this country in a way we didn't have
40 years ago all of them dedicated to
the imitation of places like harvard and
yale what kind of an sat did you need to
get in there
um i i had a high sat score
but did you get a 16 i got a 1600 yes
what did i say i got a high essay that
sounds like that what i just said is a
classic
it's a classic harvard hedge where
you're
it's sort of trying to be modest but
also begging the question so that like
harvard harvard kids are always telling
themselves that when people ask where
you go to school you should say i go to
school in boston because that way people
won't be like oh you went to harvard but
of course if you say i went to school in
boston
then the next question is oh where'd you
go bu bc and and so all you've done is
sort of kick it down the road and make
yourself look sort of
yeah anyway which is what i just did
there so yeah i got a 1600. but what did
you think when the score came in
that's probably i was pretty i was
pretty excited it's a perfect square
it's a perfect yeah i got a couple you
can get a couple questions wrong and i
didn't still get a perfect score and i
got a couple questions wrong on on the
math
time has gone by and i i people might
wonder why i'm going to ask about this
chapter but i found this to be
a
a way for you to tell us what you were
thinking about harvard and everything
else and i want to ask you about
winston bell
horn iii
winston
bell horn iii
yes
he was
um
my freshman year
he was a
homeless man
living in cambridge massachusetts
who
eventually who befriended
we were living in an entryway basically
a stairwell with rooms opening off each
side and there were four rooms going up
the stairwell and everyone in the
stairwell was very close
what was the name of the house uh
strauss
um
and strauss hall and he befriended um
one of the guys living living in that
room um but he was it was not
immediately apparent that he was a
homeless man he was he was
it i i'm still not clear whether he was
actually a con man or more of just kind
of a savant of some kind we're just sort
of
accidentally good at telling people what
they wanted to hear because first he
said that he was a graduate student and
then he said he was at the extension
school and then it became clear that
um he was just living he was just living
in cambridge showering
in the shower facilities at the athletic
facilities paint before you do that but
paint the uh
the
other members of your group there that
you live with right so this well this
room across the this room this room
across the hall um i wrote about it
because it seemed like the distillation
of
harvard and the ivy league's pursuit of
a certain kind of diversity in their
student bodies um
so you had a friend of mine who went to
who went to a new england prep school
whose grandparents had been in
government very much a sort of you know
traditional
in a sense sort of what you'd imagine a
traditional harvard harvard person to be
um his name was fourth shelby or the the
book uses a pseudonym so i'll use the
dude
all those are pseudonyms so fourth is a
pseudonym um but
it um and he and so there was him um and
there was um
my friend
uh nick i believe is i haven't is the
pseudonym nick and
damian
nick and yeah and then is it siddharth
it's siddharth yes so you had an indian
an indian american you had an africa an
indian american you had an
african-american from um from
tennessee
portuguese the uh child of immigrants
and then you had the sort of then you
had fourth who was the prep school boy
and you and me well i was across the
hall from them but i was their doors
were as close as our doors were as close
as you and i are sitting right now
describe uh
and is it also a pseudonym winston bell
horn winston bell is also a synonym
although he had a similarly outlandish
outlandish name and what described him
he was um he was african-american as
well he was huge he was probably six
foot five which is why i was convincing
when he said that he had been on the
football team i think um and he dressed
entirely in harvard apparel
harvard hat harvard jacket
i think if they you know they make
harvard running pants and he wore those
and so on um and and he was yeah i would
say he was about
you know
three times the size of some of the
girls in in the entryway so he was he
was a physically large figure and he was
incredibly friendly um
incredibly ingratiating um
and it it and he befriended um
uh damian who was who was from the south
and was black and felt uh somewhat
alienated and
being at harvard being in this and and
they became really close friends and
that was how he ended up basically
spending the night in that room
all the time and these were very small
rooms um you know we were sleeping we
were in bunk beds and there was a very
small common room and it just became a
kind of
vortex of
different kinds of
different kinds of resentments and sort
of identity politics playing out in
different ways
because forth who was the sort of you
know the the preppiest guy in the room
was also the guy who clashed the most um
and you know because we were you know 18
year old
pretentious guys would have endless
arguments about politics about you know
which is worse slavery or the holocaust
and
you can imagine how all those kinds of
arguments tended to overlap with this
bizarre um personal
living dynamic and
there was also a sort of weird dynamic
with
sort of harvard as an institution
because they clearly didn't know what to
do with this situation um you know
because he wasn't there every night he
hadn't technically moved into the room
and you know you had a racial angle that
was playing out in strange ways and so
on um
and
and right and and so and in the end this
this room um you know there was no epic
disaster at the end of it but they all
all um the guys went
sort of the room which they'd all been
incredibly close friends for about the
first couple months of the year and sort
of and it was initially an example of
sort of what a harvard ideal would look
like you know diverse backgrounds coming
together becoming great friends and so
on but by the end they had completely
split apart and everybody was going
their separate ways and
fourth roomed with friends of his from
prep school for the rest of college and
damien um you know joined the one of the
african-american choruses and sort of
so it was basically you know diversity
and then self-segregation um which is i
think one of one of the broader
realities of life at harvard that
harvard is incredibly diverse but also
incredibly segregated and you have asian
student groups and
you know tables at the dining hall
filled with asian kids and tables filled
with the prep school kids and tables
filled with the black kids and
um and the university is constantly
trying to micromanage and you know so
they'll cut down on first day
harvard kids all live in upper class
houses
uh and initially you could choose what
house you lived in and so that created
incredible self-segregation you had the
asian house you had the jock house you
had the artsy house you had the gay
house and you had all the
african-american kids living in a couple
houses and this was tremendously
embarrassing for harvard
so they randomized the houses so people
were assigned by lottery and so on um
and that was how it was when i was there
but then late in my time there they
decided well this wasn't this wasn't
even working uh it wasn't randomized
enough so it went from you could go with
16 people into your upper class house to
eight people all of it dedicated to the
idea that that you know that harvard's
job is to take these diverse people and
thrust them together and make something
something new and wonderful out of it so
what i wrote down
today's diverse campuses aren't diverse
well and that's the right and that's the
paradox is that they are diverse in
terms of in terms of ethnicity and skin
color um the ivy leagues are incredibly
i mean by the standards of colleges that
50 years ago had quotas for for for
jewish students it's it's incredible how
diverse they are but by the same token
if you look at um if you look at you
know even as diverse a room as that one
they created across the hall from me
you're still dealing with
groups of kids all of whom have usually
attended
private schools public schools in
extremely wealthy areas of the country
you're dealing with a population that
tends to come from
a very small group of states the number
of kids you know the number of kids from
massachusetts new york
connecticut california and so on is very
high number of kids from the south is
very low
um
and and if and um
and then if you look at sort of the
composition of the racial groups right
and who i i think it was um henry lewis
gates and lanigan did um
uh a study of the composition of
african-american students at harvard and
it turned out that a huge proportion
were
not the descendants of slaves they were
often the descendants of west indian
blacks immigrants
there are an awful lot of africans at
harvard from elite african families and
so on
and so you you end up with
this i mean i think it's this is crucial
to understanding the nature of the
american elite is that it thinks of
itself as much more diverse than it
actually is
um and it because it has it has sort of
diversities of
of racial background without having
deeper diversities of socioeconomic
class whatever happened to winston bell
horn
i don't know i have not i never went to
harvard he never went to i mean he he
may have taken some classes at the at
the extension
excuse me at the extension school
i'm not sure i ran into on on the the t
in boston a couple years later and he uh
he seemed to be doing well and handed me
a business card of some kind um
but
mark he was he was smart in a certain
way yeah i i mean that's the the other
interesting thing about harvard is that
it attracts
he was
just one of three or four different
people who during my time there
impersonated students in different ways
there was a kid who joined the model
united nations team and went on several
tournaments and won prizes and so on
and and joined one of the one of the
social clubs all the while only
pretending to be a student in the 10
classes and so on so
harvard seems to attract
con men of different kinds and i think
winston was a more innocent kind of con
man than some of the like he didn't you
know he he wasn't
um
yeah he there was there was no nothing
malicious i think about his attempt to
pass himself off as a harvard student as
witness by the fact that as the year
went on and it you know he didn't try
and keep up the pretense he sort of
gradually admitted well no i'm not
actually you know i'm not actually at
this school i'm not actually at this
school and so on
you wrote in your book about larry
summers of course
and someone that this
uh audience watching c-span knows
cornell west we've seen a lot of him
over the years i wondered though you
quoted leon wieseltier who
writes for the new republic which is not
a conservative publication but you quote
and i want to ask you why you did this
um
as saying in in the new republic that
cornell west's intellectual output was
quote
almost completely worthless in the nun
ellipses
noisy
tedious
slippery
humorless pedantic and self-endeared
usually when somebody goes finds a quote
like that they have a reason
why why did you put that about cornell
rest in your book
well i was i was talking about the feud
that he had with larry summers um when
summers first first came to harvard um
as president and summers there are
different just accounts of how they're
of what happened in this meeting but
basically everyone seems to agree that
summers said that
west was spending too much time being an
academic celebrity and not enough time
teaching and producing intellectual
output
and this
west was furious and offended and so on
and there were attempts and apologies
and whatnot and eventually wes decamped
to um
to to princeton um which was very happy
to have him
um and i mean i put it in because i i
agreed with it and i was sympathetic to
to
summers as much of a sort of bull in a
china shop as he was i think that
west was a good example of a certain
kind of academic superstar who becomes
an academic superstar and then
you know is neither
neither teaches nor produces serious
intellectual work
um and i think that you know i think in
certain ways many ways i think summers
was was right to take him on but it also
i mean quoting weasel tier is
interesting because a big part of
what i was talking about
in the book when i talked about the
politics of harvard um was the extent to
which conservatives don't matter at
harvard in terms of the internal
politics of a place like a place like
that and the real split is between
sen was certainly then was between
centrist liberals and the left
and the summer's west clash was a
classic you know summers as centrist
liberal west as self-conscious man of
the left prophetic revolutionary and so
on was a classic example of this
battle and of course weaselty are
writing for the new republic you know is
new republic is a liberal magazine but
it's a centrist magazine that's opposed
to the left and this was a huge dynamic
especially in the late 1990s where you
know the big thing at harvard was
the big protest on campus was the
progressive student labor movement
sitting in to protest low wages for
harvard janitors sitting into the
harvard president's office now the
harvard president neil rudenstein this
was before summers was also a liberal
there were no you know there were no
republicans involved in this debate it
was um the liberals the sort of centrist
liberals running the university against
the
uh the left which was both student
protesters but then especially
especially the faculty and that dynamic
i think probably changed a lot in the
bush era because
you know i think that the center left
and the left probably saw a lot more a
lot more eye to eye
eventually
in their distaste for bush
um
but at that point it was tremendously
important tremendously important to
understanding i think the broader
politics of america in the 1990s because
bill clinton was
you know he was sort of always
oscillating back and forth between the
center left and the left and you know
ending up basically as a kind of
centrist president who the left was
always suspicious of and so on
uh
have you seen this wong ket thing
uh perhaps perhaps not well their
headline on it is the reason i asked
because you
uh this book you wrote has a lot of
personal stuff in there and i just
wondered how i'm gonna i just want to
read to the headline and i wonder how
much you're worried about people going
back and reading it
as long as they buy it i'm having a
headline i'm happy to have them read it
the headline on this is
misogynist neckbeard ross dalton shares
his sexy stories
and then at the end of this and it's all
about a
scene in the book with you and a young
lady it says let's see
misogynous passive aggressive drunken
jerk blaming his impotence on a woman
having access to birth control we have a
winner in all caps are you worried about
this um
no i mean i think that that and why did
you write all that stuff in there
well
it's a book about it's a book about the
culture of harvard and so there's a
chapter and maybe not an entirely
successful chapter about
uh well there the chapter about romance
and a chapter about sex um
and so i you know it was it was a
personal book and so i wrote a little
bit at least about my personal
experiences and the passage that they
quote which is
describing making out with a girl
drunkenly
at a friend's party is i think by no
means the most embarrassing thing that i
wrote and certainly not the thing that
makes me cringe
the most
but
you know
as i said it's you know not not every
passage in the book is
um
not every passage in the book is
entirely successful um i think that i
think that wonkett sort of missed
well i don't know i mean you know the
the the chapter is among other things a
critique of hookup culture and a
critique of the sort of
way that the idea of safety of you know
manifested most most obviously and sort
of in
uh birth control pills and condoms but
but sort of the broad the broader way
that
the way that that's kind of a
manifestation of the broader way that
careerism is ascendant at harvard that
this extends to sex
too um to sex and romance and that in
both in both aspects people people are
incredibly careful and cautious and
focused on their career and that that's
actually i mean and again this sort of
builds out into a broader a broader
argument about american society but that
that fact is very important to
understanding the american elite and the
way the american elite thinks about sex
broadly that they
think that everyone in america is going
to be able someday with the right sex
education programs and so on to be able
to behave like
as safely as harvard students do
basically um and i was arguing that
that's
that
represents a misunderstanding of why
harvard students are so
cautious and safe and risk-averse in in
in sex because
the weight of
pressure social pressure academic
pressure and so on on an elite group
like this is so heavy in a way that it
isn't you're never going to have the
kind of culture of safe sex um
you know among working-class americans
that i think you have at a place like
harvard so anyway that's the big picture
the sort of narrow thing is a
description um of a hookup which you
know was intended
um
like
you know i mean i think that it was not
intended to show me in a flattering
light
uh is it still a hookup culture in
school yeah
what made it a hook-up culture not not
just harvard as some other places
two things um one thing was
conservatizing and one thing was
liberalizing i guess you know one thing
that made it to hookup culture was
um
was aids initially and then sort of the
broader uh broader social trends i think
that flowed from
from that it sort of revolted you know a
revolt against
deep sexual license towards a more
cautious you know a hook-up culture is
not the same thing as a culture of
promiscuity i guess you'd say because
people are
you know a hook-up is a very it's
ambiguous you're not you know in many
cases when people say they hook up they
aren't having um
they're not having sex or they're having
oral sex rather than sex they're having
you know um
the the sort of blurriness surrounding
what a hookup is um i think right
there's no relationship there well right
and that's this that's that's the second
thing that i i think that especially
um
you know and there are some differences
here i think between elite schools and
and and other colleges but um yeah i
think the culture of
campus life is not conducive to
relationships i mean i think a lot of
that has to do with just how driven
people are that the culture of sort of
careerism and overachieving that begins
i mean now it begins in kindergarten
practically makes it hard to imagine
sort of taking time off to
you know
have wild passionate love affairs or you
know and yeah
the clock's just running and i want to
ask you a couple this may all be out you
know i haven't been in school and
a quick question the the name doubtfut
is from what it's english
um i think it may have been dowthwaite
um
once a long time ago but and what day of
the week eventually will your column be
in the new york times or what day of the
week is it now online it's now online on
tuesdays i'm not sure what day of the
week it'll be in the paper and
your charge is to write
what
a conservative column no it's to write
um a column about
uh politics and culture so i think that
i'll write a lot about i'll write a lot
about politics but i'll also try and
write about
religion pop culture and american
society as well and your first book was
privileged in 2005 your second book in
2008 was grand new party um
which i co-wrote with raihan salam and
it's a book about
the republican party and um whether it
can
reimagine itself basically and come up
with a new domestic policy agenda and
you point out that raham salaam used to
be an editorial assistant to david
brooks he did yes he's now in the new
york times once a week or twice a week
twice a week and he right he was he was
brook's assistant when brooks was first
starting out on his call ross douthit
thank you very much for thank you so
much for having me
[Music]
for a dvd copy of this program call
1-877-662
for free transcripts or to give us your
comments about this program visit us at
q a dot org
q a programs are also available as
c-span podcasts
[Music]
[Music]
up next prime minister gordon brown at
the british house of commons then a
conversation with former